リジンの2
役
理事5件って皆さん日本国内にもいろんな
ファッション
ヌーます関西コレクション v ゾーン
関西で行われるファッションショーが
大きなイベントでもう本当に超有名な
モデルさんとかアイドルとか女優さん俳優
さん有名なユーチューバーといろんな形で
拭かない最大級といってもいいレベルが
ファッションそうなものを入れるんです
けども後面そこでアジア社長にステージを
プロデュースしてくれないという話を
いただきまして今回関西コレクションで
ステージをプロデュースすることになり
ました
何しましょう関西これクソもすごいれ気に
なるファッションショーだしあんまり
ふざけじゃダメなのかなと思っはいえば
ウエハーのやてぃって言われたんで僕をし
ます環境で2万円ファッションショーで服
を脱げる毒気にやっていきたいとおもい
ますターゲットは声とですそうな
トランジスター的にんですこの人しかあり
ませんほどやれから一生っていう女真面目
に服を脱ぎたいと思いあっ魚金
ファッションショー中に服が脱げるんです
が難しいことで特殊な衣装作ったり体験
どうだませんでそのですねブランドを作っ
たり結構入念に準備させていただきました
はず三郷ステージファッション業界の歴史
を変えますそう&これだけあるとちょっと
なんか面白いずになるのでもう
youtube 界きってのイケメンみっ
ちーく読んで何この3人がたギリギリ
ターゲットもガッツかなって思うように気
がしたので音の3人で最高の成長を作って
いきたいと思いますでは大阪行ってきます
か
アルミン
おはようございます
食べます
どうぞはい今再プレイ毀損でございます剤
です
すぐ出るんですよね何するかもう聞いたん
ですけど
何か新しいブランドが始まってみたい
アーサーそれが本当に最初の動き出す見て
a 肇社長と俺も出るとそれに遊べそう
ですいい
大丈夫だそれプロモーションに行ったん
でしょあっいるブランドの1傘の彼方へ
下見だよええ
あっそうなんだ会派で hemi ちょっと
メイクを張ってないんだよブーブー
ぶっ飛んできたらいいなあー
なるほどね麻生ゆうことだったはい存在服
のブランド
あとです何からだけどなんだ7倍と書い
ちゃうねそれて初めてに来て欲しい見た僕
というかそもそも担当あと3キープそうで
そこもすごいびっくり車んねアイナーさん
の方あんまりとなーんだけど言われ方へ
それアルゼません
そのサターン緑みたいなアームめっちゃ
うれしいそれはありがたいねってことも
これぬが寝てねー今回は彼らの仕事という
ことであっ酢生姜ねそうなまぁハンマーで
これ着なくちゃいけない理由たのね総合
さんが
[音楽]
ブーブー s けど
aki じゃあ
キュアサニーございます本当に小さくて
それでこいつら辺ではまずは拙速をんまえ
まず試合目確認したぞねちゃんと分切りで
あれっ
そうですやってませんぶー切り付脱ぎある
んですよドエルっ地理これでは日本の
ブランドデザインプライマーそうな枝桜
スクールしございます楽しみださっつん a
内容で何もはいなノロウイルス色パターン
じゃないですソーダ高校は大阪に落ち
くださいあればまずはまさか旗がませんよ
ね音がぶれぶれ
疑っちゃうな本当にそのつきましたねー
する省庁はお願いしますお願いしますもも
様
この日で突っつく一方でよろしいです
ちょっとためございました
今年の冬母へ
まあ
パック超 a
いいいいい
ブランド説明とおっしゃってマジでた細断
加害者か違和感ないですよ結構
アツ
へ本当に本当にあの頃当話題性があるので
僕らファッション業界で早いから10季
さんが学生時代からはや1個注目してねぇ
そんな昔からあるちゃうんですよ昔から
最近の映画も若手ですごいやつありそうね
そうなっちゃうのっ
こういうジャンルなんすかって
x してたり教育古着のリメイクバック
飯田めっちゃいっすねえええ
すごいエピソ
であればあのー
なお得って言うあー有名なセレクト
ショップ外観あるじゃないですかそので
そこで取り扱われたのは一流の
planned あーでその時李さんが
あの後ワークにあるファッションの学校の
卒業制作5分だいたい日本が保護者の人が
あふれた上でと大吾頑張って約作った年
からちょっとしたファッションショーを
やるんだけどその月さんの卒業製作所に
ヌードの有名なおなんぷるーとさん曰くて
か違って切って裏切らん yeahいいよ
まじですごい卒業生さらづ能じゃない学生
が作ったコレクション全部書いたって ae
せいで販売したもう取り扱うかないって
言っていい悪い破っそうヌードで
そこを左へ僧侶パーカ
あ
そっち
ea
直帰しかぁし
違法だとへ所海外ブランドあっえっと
ロンドン出身のデザイナーで
このベルギーアントワープ
世界中名の発祥の観光
いいみたいなブーム
ほどなるほどっからガール言ってました
もんねなんか古い木のあ本価格特にメイ
クって相馬さんですまだちょっと出せて
ないのもあるんですけどへどうぞよーあー
もーさいこーすねー
いっぱいする遊びまあユーザーの写真とり
かえっほうがいい
[音楽]
ブーブー
hatao hefe
試合あー
しかっ
日ああああああいいいい
聞いた今日のいや何となくしか
中島で服毒らの説明をしてもらってえー
すごいけど今着てるブランドらしいですよ
これからこれねくるあっ
に a
それを期さしまいですねう割が垂れる初で
ございます早いすごいですよ
だけどただ良い職の別ですけど林管理人で
今日はページでいきましょう嫌じゃない
です
[音楽]
ブーブー
s ねそれっぽいよ
パティ
ブービーいきましょう padi
[音楽]
んね
チャンネル号誰でございます
[音楽]
封筒も何かあったyeah
hey high cost a
フェニー hee
me
愛というわけでフォン満足でございます
はい
もうまさに我々3人だけのせいたので r
スケキヨだろすごいわよいいよもうこれも
ないって監修普段の我々それかっこいいお
店か今からねっ
amaran
[音楽]
ああああああ
voodoo
[音楽]
ん
me
[音楽]
しています
んん
[音楽]
ています
始まっています
すー
[音楽]
ていた
日
います日
い
ん
日
ませ
ん
[音楽]
ああいいというわけでみなさんこんにちは
こんにちは
阿蘇山会社さえ方は泣いたとですね挨拶
じゃないんお願いします
ふざけないでくださいねでお願いします前
こんにちはー
[音楽]
じゃ
あのブランド面
duty リプ9月ある
どっ
ぬゲール
二謝らないあああああ
[音楽]
内戦にん
ブーバー
しああああああ
何か負0
ていただけるってを生きてたのねー
玄関これで裸になった人いないなと思っ
てる急いないですよだからはされで
スマッシュ初夏一番教えるんですよ俺一気
見してたああってきましたええっでも
ターンこれでライトいないと思うてそれい
ない日はえん間違いでファッション史に名
を刻む
瞬間になったのではないかと思いますね
礼節ですねってこんなですいらないって
いう
ちょっとまだ最後に一言ぜひん
こんな曲試聴ありがとうございまし
たーーー
い
持っていたん
bん